yo what's going on guys christy flakes
here of bleacher report and for today's
video we are checking out a 2020 nba
redraft we are about two seasons into
these young players careers and kind of
a good idea like what you guys are gonna
be superstars all stars role players uh
god forbid busts
killian hayes please man
it's so early on his career i still
believe in a man but yes i'll we're
gonna shut up this redraft right here
you guys let me know in the comment
section below if there's one player you
could have drafted instead of who you
got realistically who would it be let me
know in the comment section below um
pistons fan i would say
man tyrese howler and kate counting him
would have absolutely loved that man but
yes ah so we're gonna go ahead and go to
the bottom of the article because it
starts at one and works its way up to
thirty so we're gonna do it this way so
with the first pick in the 2020 nba
redraft bleacher report selects uh
lamello ball on the t wolves definitely
a great pick right here lamella is
fantastic man he has a triple double uh
waiting to happen anthony edwards uh has
also fit out really nicely with the t
wolves also so i mean either way you
can't really lose um both guys have been
absolute studs in the nba so with the
second pick i can only predict it is
going to be yes anthony edwards going to
the golden state warriors so you know
the interesting about these redrafts too
is that we do kind of like look about
look at how the players are based off
the current circumstance um i think a
lot of the two was looking back at the
time and like why a certain player
wasn't drafted or why a player was
drafted and you know for the warriors i
think james wiseman just filling in that
center position with an absolute beast i
mean the team's gotten away for years
with guys like javel mcgee or like kavon
looney like seeing a generational talent
like james weisman i definitely cannot
blame them for that but also uh you know
we saw last year with clay thompson
being injured like anthony edwards would
have been on the team over there uh we
saw guys like jordan pool really step up
too many you know the young players like
that so yeah ant-man definitely would
have also made a lot of sense playing
next to curry last year and really small
uh this year they would have drafted him
uh with the third pick we got tyrese
halibur in two with the charlotte
hornets so yeah i would say lamelo is
the best point guard in this draft tyrus
halliburton not far behind he's been
absolutely beasting with the pacers
originally drafted by the kings um but
yeah the hornets got him instead of
lamelo i still think they would be just
as you know a good team if not i don't
want to say better but uh i don't know i
really like his style of play he just
always seems in control and knows
exactly what he wants to do out there uh
in the for the fourth pick we have the
chicago bulls going with tyrese maxi
instead of patrick williams so uh yeah
tyrese maxie if they were on the team
right now
you know you probably are looking at the
squad never signing limes the ball
although tyrese while he was decent last
year um it was really this year once ben
simmons was not playing at all and
tyreese kind of filled in the void right
there that it really kind of made sense
um and you know see how great a player
tyrese was and everything right man so
yeah i still like the patrick williams
pick because of positional need and what
i think he will can be for the team
going forward but uh yeah tyre's maxi i
mean
another guy that literally just you know
people may have saw potential for a
really good player but he's been a great
player and a big reason why the team
didn't really take too big of a step
back without having simmons out there uh
next up we have the cleveland cavaliers
draft one of my favorite players from
this draft class and desmond bain uh
instead of isaac ocaro desmond being if
he was on cavaliers right now um man it
would have just went together perfectly
because of the come-up of the cavaliers
this season but also desmond bane you
know six six player has that three-point
shot has good length to him um and he's
gonna be a starter for a very long time
maybe on the memphis grizzlies man i'll
see him leaving that team like they're
really building something special over
there but yeah desmond on the cavaliers
would have worked out nicely okay so now
we have the atlanta hawks going with uh
devin veselle over a kangwoo so yeah
vazel um a good 3d type of guy um the
type of player that i think that the
hawks need more of right now as opposed
to you know another big guy in a congo
because of having like cappella and john
collins kind of still plays now we have
some injuries and stuff to start things
off but vessel would have been
potentially you know a bad court mate
for uh trae young for you know five ten
years uh for the detroit pistons we got
the pistons taped and patrick williams
over killian hayes
okay so i was really all aboard the
jeremy grant for patrick williams trades
uh before the trade deadline obviously
did not happen um with that being said
though you know killian hayes
statistically speaking he's been pretty
garbage but um i did read a statistic
late on saying that like when killian's
actually in the game with kate
cunningham i think they're actually
better because of it so for whatever
that's worth but yeah patrick williams
um
you know 6a play with extreme
athleticism yes he's injured right now
but he was killed in the summer league
so i would have been a happy pistons fan
again patrick williams uh next up we
have the knicks going with denny avia
over
obi toppin so uh once again based off of
kind of what you're looking for in this
case ob topping was just a high flyer
man he was right up there was one of the
best college players uh denny avia i
think there was a little bit more like
unknowing factor when it comes to him um
you know avia definitely was
a ball handler to play but do you know
overseas and stuff like that since being
in the nba the defense is great but he
is kind of more like off ball player and
everything like that but i really think
either way the knicks wouldn't have lost
i like what obi does i think maybe a
little bit is that he's behind you know
julius randle the rotation stuff like
that some of you don't see as much out
of ob as you would have liked but you
know nonetheless still not bad uh here
we have the wizards going with cole
anthony uh and you know cole anthony um
another point guard that i think kind of
got like overlooked by guys you know
having like lamello out there and uh
tyrese halliburton and you know guards
like that and everything man so
yeah him on the wizards especially
knowing that dinwiddie wasn't gonna work
out and uh you know eventually russell
westbrook wasn't going to work out cole
anthony would have stepped right in i
think it would have been perfect
alongside bradley beale would have been
a very athletic and high scoring uh bad
courts um next up we got the phoenix
suns with emmanuel quickly i actually
love emmanuel quickly and uh assuming
they still would have got chris paul out
of this which you think they would have
uh
man like quickly as a six-man kind of
combo guard you know jordan clarkson
type would have been perfect and i still
think that's maybe what the phoenix suns
could still use right now man so yeah
jalen smith ended up getting traded away
and everything but quickly uh would have
been part of the championship rotation
um next up we have the spurs going with
beef stew isaiah stewart over devin
vessel so they do have yaka purdle but
uh by getting you know beef stew it
allows them to move on from more veteran
older yacht purple still have the high
energy guy and isaiah stewart on the
team
uh we have the kings going with sadiq
bay
over tyree's halliburton so i think in a
few cases here um you know watching bay
he can be very streaky like sometimes he
just looks like okay this is a sophomore
player and other times like wow you see
a future all-star right here um i
probably would have drafted him a little
bit higher probably even over isaiah
stewart to be honest i like sadiq bay a
lot him going to this king's team him
you know with dear fox um would have
been a nice little duo to have
uh next up we have the pelicans with
jaden mcdaniels you know kind of a three
level type of score which you know next
to ingram uh this season special design
being out would have been uh nice and
everything carol lewis jr i still think
shows promise but uh with him it's like
you know well he has like i think he's
out with injury and everything too so
you know but we don't know how that's
gonna slow him down and everything going
forward hopefully not too much uh and we
got the boston celtics was isaac okoro
over and aaron the smith so the carl you
do get that defensive type of guy uh him
playing the back quarter times with
marcus smart would have been absolutely
lethal defensively so yes that gets us
through the lottery picks uh so let's
kind of go quicker here through the rest
of the we got kang
to the magic so probably playing behind
wendell and uh mo bamba but still a high
energy guy on the team
uh we got the pistons going with uh
pukashevsky who i personally
one of my is probably one of my worst
takes of all time to start the season i
poke ski as the most improved player
candidate
he was really good to end the season for
the okc thunder i still would have took
him i still see a lot of uh potential in
pukashevsky uh we got the t wolf's going
with opie top and his athleticism next
carl clinton towns you know run up down
the court also with uh well in this case
lamella instead of anthony edwards uh
that would have been a lot of fun we got
the mavericks going with james weisman
so yeah the fall for james weisman is
strictly because of injuries and him not
really playing too much and when he has
played he always looked like a rookie
and stuff like that so um but yeah james
wiseman big body for luka doncic to work
with heck yeah man uh we got the pistons
going with zeke ray here um i honestly
don't know too much about him but he's
shooting 45 from deep on his career oh i
like that he has joined the team man i
prefer sadiq bay though personally uh
mayan hega and kenyon martin uh junior
over precious ochuwa
uh we got the 76ers with trey jones over
tyreese maxie jordan noira over i guess
i'm sorry jordan laura over on the
denver nuggets like them on the
milwaukee bugs i still think he has
potentially really good score here in
the nba just has a good uh body for you
know the league and everything t wolves
peyton pritchard um really good rookie
season on the celtics
denver nuggets with kara lewis the
junior uh we got the knicks getting r.j
hampton boston celtics getting killian
hayes which is a six-man you know kind
of operate in the second unit wouldn't
have been bad although killian hayes
kind of is what the celtics could
actually use man um as a point guard i
would
say uh utah jazz xavier tillman over
azabuike uh t wolf's going with josh
screen over jaina mcdaniels
uh malachi flynn with malachi flint hey
the raptors hey the only one taking
their same player right here you like it
and the memphis grizzlies presses the
chuwa i still can't not believe that
desmond bane was the 30th pick in the
draft man like oh he would just look
like he was ready to be
uh you know i would have said at this
point you're probably saying a lottery
pick right man but yes that is all we
have for this video what you guys think
about this redraft let me know in the
comment section below thank you all so
much for watching and peace out my
friends